l'ordre du jour appelle le débat sur les
conclusions du rapport de la commission
denquête pour l'évaluation des
politiques publiques face aux grandes
pandémies à la lumière de la crise
sanitaire de lakovic 19 et de sa gestion
demande de la commission denquête cette
séance s'organisera en deux temps la
parole sera donnée à l'auteur du débat
un orateur de chaque groupe est au
ministre pour leur répondre
nous procéderons ensuite à une séquence
de 16 questions réponses la parole est
tout d'abord à l'orateur de la
commission de kate qui a demandé ce
débat monsieur alain milon président de
la commission denquête pour 8 minutes
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre
dans leur combat contre les épidémies
les hommes ont fait d'immenses progrès
les vaccins et les traitements ont
permis de faire reculer les ravages
provoqués par les maladies infectieuses
à tel point que l'effroi qu'elles ont
causés à nos ancêtres étaient presque
oublié locaux vides 19 est venue nous
rappeler les règles de base de lutte
contre les épidémies
elles se résument en trois actions qui
ont connu une actualité nouvelle mais
ont aussi été reformulée à mesure que
notre pays réalisé qu'il n'était pas en
mesure de tout les accomplir
testez tracé isolé repérer les personnes
atteintes identifier celles qu'elles
sont susceptibles d'avoir contaminé
isoler les malades et les personnes
contacts afin de limiter la propagation
de la maladie et ainsi progressivement
casser la dynamique des contaminations
en l'absence de vaccins et de
traitements cette stratégie est la seule
disponible et a fait la preuve de son
efficacité
pourtant après avoir consciencieusement
appliqués au tout début de l'épidémie
le gouvernement semble y avoir en tout
ou partie renoncer les français
rapatriés de william ont été testés et
mis à l'isolément dans un centre de
vacances les personnes atteintes du
cluster des contamines ont été isolés à
l'hôpital les personnes duc leicester de
creil ont été isolés dans les conditions
définies par le service de santé des
armées
mais après sur les trois pans de la
stratégie la constance mais aussi les
moyens ont fait défaut malgré un
développement rapide à l'honneur des
équipes de recherche
le déploiement des tests a connu un
déploiement hésitant et laborieux le
passage au stade industriel se révélant
extrêmement complexe il en est résulté
tout d'abord une approche malthusienne
du recours aux tests
alors que certains de nos voisins testé
beaucoup plus massivement et que
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
exhorté les états à le faire certaines
capacités
les laboratoires privés vétérinaire ou
encore universitaires ont été laissés à
l'écart pour des raisons administratives
qui n'était pourtant plus de mise
pendant la crise leur réintégration dans
le jeu s'est faite au moment même où le
revirement du gouvernement sur
l'élargissement des personnes à tester
percuté de plein fouet des capacités de
test encore trop peu organisée pendant
le trop longues semaines notre pays à
tester tester tester
conformément aux recommandations de l
oms mais en pure perte les résultants de
parvenant aux intéressés qu'au delà de
la période où il aurait été utile
pendant toute cette période la détection
de cas continuer à se faire à l'hôpital
pour des personnes symptomatique d'un
stade de gravité avancée est évidemment
trop tard pour organiser un quelconque
le traçage sur le traçage précisément
nous n'avons guère été meilleur
la recherche d'une sophistication
excessive s'est traduite par des retards
et une perte globale d'efficacité là où
d'autres pays
je pense en particulier à la corée dont
le représentant a été entendu par la
commission denquête on était mieux
organisé l'ambassadeur de france en
corée a insisté sur le caractère assez
rustique des moyens déployés à rebours
de l'image que d'aucuns avaient
spontanément d'outils numériques qui
serait intrusif et quasi totalitaire il
s'agissait au contraire de mobiliser le
plus de moyens possibles et d'agir vite
ce que nous n'avons pas fait le centre
une fois de plus de côté les médecins de
ville qui voyait pourtant dans leur
cabinet la majeure partie des personnes
atteintes de acco vide je serai bref car
je ne veux pas être cruel sur l'échec
programmé d'emblée de l'application
stock co vide
cet échec est collectif cet outil a été
conçu avec tellement de prérequis que
nous ne savions qu'ils font qui ne
fonctionneraient pas et que quelque part
nous ne sautons pas qui fonctionne
vraiment
cet échec a pesé sur la capacité
d'appliquer de l'application tous en
psycho vide à se faire une place sur les
téléphones de nos concitoyens
aujourd'hui encore une majorité
écrasante de cas positifs est passé sous
le radar du traçage ce qui témoigne
d'une efficacité très relative
je voudrais faire une place singulière
car je sais que ma position sur le sujet
n'a pas toujours été comprise à la
question de l' isolement des malades et
des personnes contactent il se trouve
que la commission des affaires sociales
avait eu à se pencher sur ce sujet peu
de temps avant le déclenchement de
l'épidémie à la faveur de l'examen
sur le rapport de notre collègue martin
lévriers d'une proposition de loi de
notre ancien collègue michel amiel le
texte visé les cas de tuberculose
résistante mais la question est la même
que faire face à un malade contagieux
qui risque de susciter une flambée
épidémique
notre commission avait alors suggéré de
donner une compétence clair aux préfets
la base juridique prévue par le code de
la santé publique ayant été jugée
fragile
le gouvernement a souhaité proposer un
autre cadre au parlement le premier
ministre d'alors avait défini ce cadre
dans les termes suivants je cite
isolement doit être expliquée consentis
et accompagner il s'agissait de s'en
remettre au civisme de chacun
pas question d'isoler des personnes
testées positives
pas question d' isoler dans les
aéroports dans l'attenté des résultats
d'un test ce que font pourtant bon
nombre de nos partenaires et dans des
conditions parfois coûteuses pour les
intéresser les capacités hôtelières
était pourtant disponibles pour
organiser un isolement efficace dans un
contexte de mise à l'arrêt des
déplacements professionnels et du
tourisme
la présidente de la région ile de france
a indiqué à la commission denquête à
voir proposer la réservation de sept
mille lits dont le pilotage aurait été
confiée à l'agencé régionale de santé
c'est bien la volonté qui a fait défaut
il peut sembler étrange et un an après
le déclenchement de la crise sanitaire
de reprendre ainsi le fil des événements
et de revenir sur la stratégie conduite
alors que nous sommes toujours englués
dans cette épidémie
l'objectif de la commission denquête
était d'examiner le degré de préparation
de notre pays face à l'épidémie
il est évident que nous n'étions pas
prêts mais aussi de définir ce que nous
pourrions faire pour être prêt à
l'avenir une nouvelle fois ce que nous
pourrions faire en l'absence de vaccin
de traitement s'est testé tracé isoler
le faisons nous pleinement la réponse
est non on avoue non les moyens
ce n'est pas certain le développement de
tests moins contraignant reste à faire
et le contact racing reste à améliorer
en avons-nous et à volonté la question
mérite d'être posée et je vous propose
de nous interroger collectivement
que ferions nous demain devant une
maladie beaucoup plus contagieuse est
beaucoup plus létal pour l'ensemble de
la population
devrions-nous faire des choix et
conserver la même stratégie
j'espère que le débat de cet après midi
pourra nous permettre de répondre à
cette question elle pose tout à la fois
la question de la responsabilité
individuelle de la responsabilité
politique et de la confiance que les
citoyens ont dans leurs dirigeants et
réciproquement
ce n'est qu'en tirant des leçons de ce
qui s'est passé que nous pourrons
progresser
c'est ce à quoi la commission denquête
sept employés et j'espère que sur le
fondement de ces recommandations nous
pourrons avancer
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président dans la
suite du débat la parole est aux
orateurs et oratrice des groupes la
parole pour commencer un monsieur
bernard jomier pour le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains pour sept
minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre ce président de la commission
cher collègue sara port dans ce que nous
avons produit avec mes collègues
rapporteure catherine de roche et sylvie
vermeillet dont je salue ici la qualité
du travail que nous avons fait un commun
en commun ça rapport danse et qui s'est
attaché à analyser la qualité de la
réponse de notre pays et surtout à
proposer des pistes pour que notre
système de santé tire les leçons de
cette épidémie est ce rapport a été
intitulée pour un nouveau départ en
santé publique car nous avons partagé
le constat que notre pays a su
construire ces dernières décennies un
système de soins un système hospitalier
un système de soins de ville qui ont
leurs difficultés on les connaît bien
mais qu'il a beaucoup moins su
construire un système de santé publique
et que ce n'est pas un hasard si des
pays qui avaient vécu une situation
épidémique en 2003 pour beaucoup mieux
répondu en 2020 en 2019 2020 pardon à la
crise parce qu'ils avaient en fait
modifier leur approche
tirant les leçons de l'epide de
l'épidémie 2003 peut-on ensemble formé
le voeu que nous sachions tirer les
leçons de cette crise que ce serait là
l'essentiel est que nous sachions
modifier notre système de santé publique
en conséquence une des grandes leçons
que nous avons tirées c'est que nous
avions un défaut d'adaptation et ce
défaut d'adaptation fait que la réponse
qui est produite est souvent uniforme et
souvent verticale et souvent décidé d'en
haut on peut dire qu'elle décale que le
système politique du pays après tout
mais on peut pas s'en satisfaire
et la question que je voudrais poser
aujourd'hui c'est quand allons nous
tirer ses leçons et quand allons nous
prendre des dispositions qui modifient
notre approche de la crise on voit par
exemple que sur le secteur de la culture
persiste une réponse uniforme d'art et
ou de toutes les activités alors que
vivre avec le virus
on en maîtrisant au maximum la
circulation pour ne pas saturer notre
système de santé c'est la stratégie
générale ne nécessite pas d'arrêter
uniformément toutes les activités
culturelles
l'adaptation n'est toujours pas faite
même si elle commence à être annoncé on
a vu que dans le deux langues dans le
domaine du commerce
après une première phase je ne parle pas
du printemps la sidération et tout le
monde convient que cette sidération
s'est imposé à nous tous
mais à l'automne cette approche du but
esque de décider d'ouverture ou de
fermeture enfants fonction de la qualité
du bien acheté et non pas des conditions
sanitaires de l'achat commence à être
modifié lors des dernières annonces du
premier ministre où c'est plus les
conditions sanitaires de l'achat qui
autorise ou n'autorise pas l'ouverture
de tel ou tel commerce
l'adaptation est donc très très lente et
nous appelons monsieur le ministre à ce
que notre pays aille plus vite en la
matière des réponses pourraient être
apportées en termes de gouvernance
alors j'entends le discours qui est de
dire on verra après la crise mais il
aura pas un jour où la montre dira c'est
fini et où une nouvelle page se tournera
il ya une phase suraigu il ya des
épisodes aigus encore peut-être
entreront nous demain après-demain dans
une phase chronique mais je crois que
plus d'un an après que l'épidémie et
surgit il est temps d'adopter des
modifications qui sont nécessaires et on
le parlement devrait en les y ferrer
après tout on va bien légiférer une
proposition de loi sur la santé qui est
assez brouillonne qui est assez confuse
pourquoi monsieur le ministre ne
serait-il pas le temps d'une loi
d'adaptation du système de santé aux
leçons de lakovic 19 caen en débattrons
nous la stratégie d'y vivre avec c'est
trop traduit par arrêté de gif parfois
mais surtout encore une fois par la
difficulté de territorialiser les
réponses et parfois il faut être plus
restrictif et c'est dommage que l'on
n'ait pas eu une approche plus perry et
orial des mesures restrictives quand
l'épidémie était très différente d'un
territoire à l'autre
peut-être ce n'est plus l'heure pour la
situation actuelle et peut-être demain
de nouvelles mesures restrictives seront
nationale mais on peut regretter que
cette approche n'est pas été plus
développés parce qu'on constate tous on
sait tous qui a des territoires il ya
des villages de bretagne qui depuis
non non pas juin quatre co vide et qui
depuis un an sont soumis aux mêmes
restrictions ou quasiment
ou quasiment que les autres territoires
de notre pays
le vivre avec monsieur le premier
ministre
un jour on espère qu'il s'arrêtera et
donc nos capacités d'anticipation car
aussi nous avons été critique il faut le
dire sur des défauts d'anticipation
devrait amener à une réflexion porter
collectivement sur le fait de savoir
quand nous pourrons passer à une
stratégie d'éradication d'élimination du
virus après tout vous nous avez annoncé
le 12 janvier que nous aurions 77
millions de doses de vaccins disponibles
au mois de juin le chiffre de 135 137
millions a été avancé aussi le chef de
l'état a annoncé qu'elles étaient tous
les français qui le souhaitent
pourraient être vaccinés est ce que les
conditions d'une stratégie d'un
changement de stratégie vers
l'éradication du virus seront posées
dans quelques mois
eh bien ça mérite que ce soit discutée
que ce soit anticipée et pas seulement
au sein du conseil de défense
pas seulement par des travaux du conseil
scientifique mais parce que la
démocratie sanitaire a trop souffert
pendant cette épidémie que ce soit
discuté avec les acteurs de santé que ça
discutait avec les élus des territoires
que ce soit discuté ici au parlement
nous avons la conviction monsieur le
ministre que cette crise doit nous
apprendre collectivement à une démarche
de santé publique
revivifiée à une meilleure association
des différents acteurs et que si nous
réussissons collectivement ce pari les
victimes beaucoup trop nombreuses de
cette épidémie auront au moins servi à
ce que nous améliorons notre système de
santé sur merci
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant pour le groupe les
indépendants à emmanuel capus pour cinq
minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues 80000 c'est
le nombre de victimes provisoire de
cette épidémie et c'était évidemment eux
que je pense au moment de prendre la
parole dans cet hémicycle
dès les premiers jours de la crise le
sénat a agi il a permis au gouvernement
de prendre les mesures d'urgence qui
s'imposait nous avons voté ici en
responsabilité l'état d'urgence
sanitaire et 4 plfr dans le but
d'identifier des pistes d'amélioration
des politiques publiques
notre chambre à créer une commission
denquête dont nous débattons aujourd'hui
et des conclusions et les commissions
dans quatre mes chers collègues sont
d'autant plus intéressante qu'elle
cherche à être impartial et à faire la
lumière sur des événements passés en
l'espèce à ce stade nous manquons
cruellement de recul pour tirer des
conclusions définitives sur la gestion
d'une crise à laquelle nous continuons
malheureusement à faire face la france
comme le monde entier a subi les effets
d'une pandémie qui nous a tous surpris
certains pays
déjà habitué à ces épidémies comme
taïwan et la corée du sud
je crois qu'il faut le préciser que le
président ont réagi très rapidement
d'autres au contraire ont pris plus de
temps comme les etats-unis ou le
royaume-uni
le ms a elle-même tardé à tirer la larme
sur cette urgence de santé publique les
efforts que la chine a déployé pour
cacher les début de l'épidémie ils sont
sans doute en partie responsable ces
efforts se poursuivent d'ailleurs et l'
enquête sur les origines du virus menée
en chine n'est pas facile et on constate
encore même le déni du nombre de décès
dans cette république populaire
à l'heure où nous parlons et malgré
cette opacité
les pires scénarios ont été évités le
séquençage du virus s'est fait en
quelques semaines et un vaccin a été mis
au point en quelques mois on peut bien
évidemment regretté que la france n'en
est pas encore mis au point et à titre
personnel je le regrette vivement
mais notre pays a connu un bilan connaît
un bilan qui pourrait être pire
même si c'est toujours trop la france
connaît aujourd'hui moins de morts par
jour que l'allemagne pourtant si souvent
cité en exemple
il emporte malgré tout déterminé comment
notre pays aurait pu faire mieux comme
seul et proposer notre commission le
premier sujet évidemment sur lequel nous
avons travaillé ça a été le sujet des
masques
ces protections qui nous ont cruellement
fait défaut au printemps stratégie de
lutte contre la propagation du virus
le stock de masques de l'état était
fortement à sécher au cours des
dernières années c'est un fait
celui des ffp2 a presque été réduits à
néant de 2011 à 2016 celui des masques
chirurgicaux a été imputée en 2018 2 86%
à posteriori il apparaît évident que ces
réductions sont sensiblement ont
sensiblement accru la vulnérabilité de
notre pays à en croire la tension sur le
marché nous n'étions pas les seuls à en
avoir urgemment besoin
bien sûr il ya d'autres ressources qui
nous ont également fait défaut comme le
curare et les respirateurs mais ces
pénuries ont été résolus plus rapidement
au delà de la conservation de stocks
stratégiques et de la préservation de
notre souveraineté
la coopération dans la résolution de la
crise reste l'un des points
d'amélioration majeure
il faudra qu'elle soit encore renforcée
entre les pays européens
au niveau national la coopération a eu
lieu entre les régions en matière de
santé elle a été positive et nous
souhaitons qu'elle se poursuive
il convient également de permettre à la
médecine de ville d' apporter tout son
concours au secteur hospitalier dans ces
périodes de crise mais aussi en temps
normal pour une meilleure prévention
il en va de même pour les capacités de
test dont il a été largement parlée par
mes prédécesseurs il aurait en effet
et profitable d'associer les différents
laboratoires y compris vétérinaire pour
effectuer davantage de tests dans de
meilleures conditions
john abbott je n'aborde pas non plus la
question de la contrainte
même si à titre personnel il me semble
qu'il aurait fallu se la poser et qu'il
faudra sans doute se la poser dans le
futur je pense évidemment à l' isolement
mais également aux passeports vaccinaux
enfin il serait certainement bénéfique
de mieux associer les collectivités
territoriales au fonctionnement des ars
mais aussi aux décisions prises par
l'état comme souvent nos territoires ont
tenté d'apporter leur concours mais des
rigidités administratives ont freiné
leur initiative voici mes chers
collègues quelques enseignements que
l'on peut tirer de la gestion française
d'une pandémie qui n'est pas terminée
d'autres questions nombreuses restent en
suspens elle touche principalement à
notre souveraineté économique sanitaire
mais aussi aux conséquences pour notre
jeunesse et pour nos forces vives
ces questions devront nécessairement
trouver des réponses
merci sarko l'oeil la parole est
maintenant madame raymonde poncet mange
pour le groupe écologiste pour cinq
minutes
merci
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
monsieur le rapporteur mercière
collègues
ce rapport porte sur l'une des crises
les plus graves que nous ayons connue et
ses conclusions sont accablantes
l'excellent travail de la commission d'
enquête nous a appris que les adeptes du
ministère de la santé en janvier ont été
ignorés par l'exécutif et l'union
européenne que le grand test a livré
presque seule une bataille désespérée
contre l'extension exponentielle du
virus que les choix de la direction
générale de la santé ont empêché la
reconstitution des stocks stratégiques
de masques qui ont cruellement manqué
durant plusieurs mois
information d'ailleurs dissimulée à
l'opinion par pression politique et que
ce sont les populations les plus
vulnérables les plus relayé qui ont été
surexposé et les plus durement touchés
par le virus sans que rien ne soit fait
alors ni depuis pour améliorer leurs
conditions et la reconnaissance de leur
métier
ces manquements ces négligences de
l'état ont coûté la vie à des milliers
de personnes la responsabilité de l'état
est ainsi engagée les recommandations
proposées par le rapport sont justes il
faut en effet reconstituer le stock
stratégique de masques
il faut aussi sortir de l'hospital au
centrisme et intégrer les établissements
médico sociaux comme un service
domiciliaire dans notre système de santé
afin de mieux protéger les populations
vulnérables
il faut faire vivre la démocratie
sanitaire dans l'hôpital mais aussi en
prenant appui sur l'expertisé des
associations et celle des collectivités
territoriales proche du terrain
toutefois pour compléter ses
recommandations et renforcer
véritablement nos capacités de
résilience face aux crises à venir
ils sont nécessaire de rappeler
également que la gravité de cette
pandémie trouve aussi ses causes dans
les politiques d'austérité budget
r mené depuis des dizaines d'années
cassan l'hôpital public déstructurant la
recherche et accroissant les inégalités
sociales et territoriales
bien avant la coved les hôpitaux publics
étaient au bord de l asphyxie en cause
l'ondam systématiquement insuffisant
obligeant des économies non pertinentes
à la suppression de cent mille dix ans
vingt ans et la volonté de transformer
les hôpitaux en entreprise rompu au lean
management à la t2a et au virage
ambulatoire à marche forcée qui ont
conduit un système de santé sous tension
permanente au moment du choc de la
pandémie
dès lors par exemple nombre d'opérations
duel des programmes et la prévention et
le dépistage suspendu entraînant des
pertes de chances de plus face à la
pénurie de masques de tests de personnel
le gouvernement n'a pas suffisamment agi
soit parce qu'il n'a pas appelé à la
collaboration mais soit aussi par
résistances idéologiques à impliquer les
loi de réquisition sanitaire doit être
aussi questionné l'hyperprésidentialisme
concentre autour de lui un conseil de
défense
un conseil scientifique un comité
d'analysé de recherche et un autre
conseil scientifique sur les vaccins
épaulé par trois cabinets de conseil
privé qui se surajoutent à nos agences
sanitaires et dont le fonctionnement
reste opaque sans contrôle public du
parlement et des acteurs du territoire
ce chevauchement de comités et de
cabinets brouille la gouvernance
sanitaire et le rôle d'agent ce
d'ailleurs sous dimensionné comme santé
publique france empêché dans ses
missions d'expertisé et de gestion des
situations sanitaires exceptionnel enfin
il faut que cette crise refusent une
transformation profonde de nos modes de
vie car la crise découle de
l'effondrement de la biodiversité
une étude de l'université de cambridge
démontre que la migration des espèces de
déforestation et au dérèglement
climatique a permis la transmission de
lakovic 19 à l'être humain depuis 20 ans
les scientifiques nous alertent les
pandémies se multiplient nous sommes
rentrés dans le temps de pandémie
à la faveur de la dévastation des forêts
et la biodiversité
c'est bien que ce soit pas totalement
l'objet bien sûr de ce rapport mais
c'est long trois raisons profondes de
cette crise qui aurait mérité
y compris des romains recommandations à
nos forces politiques des
recommandations en soi notamment la non
ratification des traités de libre et or
et les changes comme le mercosur
la leçon est bien qu'il nous faut
changer de modèle
passer d'une politique publique curative
ça a été dit dans le dans la santé à une
politique préventive
la défense de la biodiversité doit
accompagner la défense d'une société
résiliente respectueuse du vivant et
dont le paradigme devient le soin et la
justice sociale chevron merci merci
chers collègues
la parole est maintenant pour le groupe
air des pays à monsieur françois patriat
pour cinq minutes
monsieur le président nous sûmes
ministre chargé des solidarités de la
santé monsieur le président la
commission denquête mesdames messieurs
les rapporteurs mes chers collègues
encore inconnu il ya moins d'un an la
comédienne a donné lieu à une crise
sanitaire inédits dont l'ampleur
semblait à l'époque davantage disques
optiques trois visages ap
nous sommes réunis ce jour pour un débat
sur la crise dans son ensemble mais non
les sur les conclu mme non pas seul
c'est un débat sur la crise mais sur les
conclusions du rapport de la commission
denquête la constitution de celle ci
s'inscrit pleinement dans le rôle de
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
talent par le parlement dans notre
responsabilité vis-à-vis des français
cette mission est essentielle nous y
sommes bien évidemment favorable c'est
le commission denquête a réalisé un
travail qu'il faut souligner est que les
sénateurs de notre groupe salue 133
personnes auditionnées donc au cours des
quarante cet entretien ses 102 heures de
ne permettre pourtant pas d'établir un
constat exhaustif de la gestion d'une
crise sanitaire mondiale est unique
comment contrôler l'action du
gouvernement face à une épidémie qui
faisait encore hier 439 victimes en 24
heures comment critiquer des mesures
sans le recul nécessaire à une analyse
raisonnée ni sans même ne pouvoir
établir de comparaison efficace
il ya un an tout juste le bilan humain
de la copie 19 dépasser celui du strass
avec 814 décès confirmés mondialement
aujourd'hui on en dénombre 2 millions 1
en deux vagues de reprise d'accalmie et
maintenant de variants 12 mois de geste
barrière à s'approprier 12 mois de vie
sociale à l'arrêt plus de 3 millions de
cas détectés et 2 millions de doses de
vaccin administrées aussi prenant acte
des conclusions du rapport et bien que
cet exercice soit indispensable nous
émettons une forte réserve quant à la
temporalité de cette publication
cette situation exceptionnelle va
forcément poser certains écueils
il serait utopique de prétendre le
contraire pour autant le temps du bilan
arrivera plus tard lorsque les hôpitaux
auront enfin un répit et que les
chiffres de contamination ne rythme
rompu nos vies alors l'analyse sera
efficace est essentielle mais pas
maintenant
ce temps long
nous oblige à ne pas porter de jugements
trop hâtifs ce temps l'on force à
l'humilité la commission il faut le
rappeler a débuté ses travaux durant les
vacances d'été
alors que les courbes et est au plus bas
elle les a poursuivis pendant la
campagne des élections sénatoriales
les faits démontrent aujourd'hui que
nous ne partageons plus certaines des
certitudes que nous avions eue hier les
pays aux stratégies vu comme exemplaire
lors de la première vague ne sont plus
actuellement pourrait vous en citer
quelques exemples
malheureusement aujourd'hui la situation
de nos voisins d'outre-rhin s'est
dégradée mes chers collègues si la
comparaison s'avère souvent utiles en
matière de gestion de crise sanitaire
elle n'est pas pour autant une science
exacte et la fascination pour d'autres
pays qui ferait mieux ont telle ou telle
chose mais qui dans le même temps par
exemple ont fermé leur école depuis 8 9
mois la comparaison chaque jour ne
prenons pas chaque jour l'exemple qui
serait être mieux dans notre pays dans
l'autre dans d'autres pays alors que non
le nôtre la situation doit être regardée
avec lucidité
concernant les masques et la gestion des
stocks
ils ont été le point central de bon
nombre de nos discussions le chiffre de
1 milliard est fréquemment revenus des
rapports taux se sont semble-t-il
focaliser sur un nombre sans avoir une
réflexion sur la gestion exacte des
stocks
c'est pour autant bien cela qui fait
désormais défaut au départ oui le point
d'interrogation demeure
oui forcé d'accepter de ne pas avoir ni
quand ni comment cette pandémie prendra
fin nous ne savons pas aujourd'hui savez
si on avait évoqué d'autres ensembles le
fait que nous serions aujourd'hui face à
une troisième vague possible enfin
existantes à des mesures plus dures au
corps à prendre qui l'aurait cru il y a
un an
cette adaptation était crucial et les
chiffres semblent actuellement démontré
son efficacité
la ligne de crête a obligé le
gouvernement à faire preuve d' équilibre
entre liberté et restrictions entre
gestes barrière avec confinement entre
ouverture souhaitée de tous et fermeture
nécessaire pour tous oui nous ne
manquerions d'objectivité en affirmant
le contraire
la france n'était pas prête à faire face
à un phénomène totalement nouveau d'une
telle ampleur mais aucun pays n'était
prêt pour autant un an plus tard le
constat nepad n'est pas si noir que le
rapport de la commission denquête mais
souligne aux prémices de la crise
épidémique les évacuations sanitaires
ont très largement permis de les
or j'ai les hôpitaux les territoires les
plus touchés je connais en particulier
le territoire dont je suis l'élu la
vaccination des publics prioritaires
fonctionne la coopération européenne
dont la france était moteur est établi
et notre capacité de tête est exemplaire
en europe qui dit aujourd'hui que les
tests sont gratuits en france on qui
coûte 100 euros en allemagne 300 euros
au royaume-uni personnel d'un rapport au
delà des mesures sanitaires mais parce
que cette crise est crucial et
économique également l'accompagnement
des personnes en isolement le soutien
aux jeunes
le fonds de solidarité en faveur des
entreprises et la gratuité des tests et
des vaccins honore notre pays
la solidarité dont le besoin et la
fraternité devant cette situation qui
touche nos concitoyens de manière
inégale sont les forces stabilisatrice
sur cette ligne de crête que nous
suivons forme chers collègues l'avaient
compris les sénateurs du groupe r des
pays s'accordent à dire qu'une réelle
commission de prospective et de
préconisations est importante mais elle
se fait en dehors de toute polémique
politicienne
une fois la crise passée alors plutôt
qu'une attitude de défiance permanente
de critique systématique
nous préférons aujourd'hui accompagner
le gouvernement dans les mesures
d'adaptation il aurait pu aussi à
quelques collègues qu'il a su prendre à
chaque instant pour faire en sorte
qu'aujourd'hui nous puissions non
seulement résister poursuivre dans le
même temps éviter site est possible à
confinement pour tous je vous remercie
bien merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à véronique guillotin pour le
groupe rds pour cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission denquête mesdames et
messieurs mesdames et monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues chateaubriand
chateaubriand dans ses mémoires
d'outre-tombe affirmé que presque
toujours en politique le résultat est
contraire à la prévision la pandémie
liée à la coved 19 était-elle prévisible
c'est pour certains chercheurs elles
n'étaient pas inimaginable son angle son
ampleur semble avoir pris par surprise
le monde entier sa gestion rethel pu
suivre un autre court certainement
peut-on en tirer des leçons sur les
plans organisationnel décisionnel ou
culturelles évidemment c'est ce constat
qui a motivé la création d'une
commission d' enquête au sein de notre
assemblée je tiens d'ailleurs à saluer
l'ensemble des rapporteurs qui ont
effectué un travail remarquable
ce rapport de nous permettre
d'identifier les dysfonctionnements et
leurs origines et en faire des sources
de progrès c'est de manière dépassionnée
que nous avons entrepris cette tâche de
manière rigoureuse également nous
gardons de juger le passé à la lumière
de ce que nous savons aujourd'hui mais
en ayant un oeil critique sur le
déroulement de la situation
c'est dans cet état d'esprit que je
souscris majoritairement différentes
préconisations des rapporteurs et
jacques sereys mon propos sur quelques
points puisque les cinq minutes qui me
sont accordées ne permettent pas de
balayer les centaines de pages et
l'ensemble des préconisations du rapport
les travaux de la commission denquête
ont tout d'abord mis en exergue
l'impréparation et l'absence
d'anticipation
un constat largement partagé par la
mission d'évaluation nommé par le
président de la république quand
l'épidémie s'est répandue sur le
territoire français nous nous sommes
retrouvé démuni démunis al'inverse de
certains autres pays comme taiwan
effectivement singapour ou la corée du
sud mais qui eux avaient culturellement
beaucoup appris de la pandémie du strass
2003 et de la grippe a en 2009 et pour
lesquelles l'expérience du passé était
déjà que se prépare à l'incertitude mais
le contexte culturel n'est pas
comparable
cette impréparation c'est
essentiellement par conte illustré au
départ par un défaut de stratégie tester
tracé isolé mais pas une mais par une
pénurie également de protection
individuelle et une capacité de
production quasi inexistante sur notre
territoire puisqu'il n'existe plus
aujourd'hui sur le sol de véritables
filières industrielles de production la
dernière usine ayant fermé ses portes en
pourtant le haut conseil de la santé
publique en 2011 santé publique france
en 2018 préconisé la constitution d'un
stock stratégique de masques qui à
l'instar des sur blouse ou des gants ont
cruellement fait défaut à nous soignants
professionnels des ehpad mais surtout
aux aides à domicile qui ont parfois
rempli leur mission au péril de leur vie
le premier le premier des engagements à
à cette leçon la première et des
engagements à prendre c'est bien sûr de
sécuriser la gestion de nos stocks de
masques nos stocks de médicaments nos
stocks de vaccins et cela doit passer
aussi par la relocalisation de leur
production à l'échelle européenne nous
pourrions penser que cette impréparation
de début allait nous servir de leçon
pour anticiper l'organisation de la
vaccination d'ailleurs j'avais eu
l'occasion d'alerter sur ce point en
novembre dernier lors d'une crue âgées
pour autant j'ai l'impression que
l'anticipation sur le recueil des
consentements anticipé en ehpad sur la
variation dans la stratégie de
déploiement des centres nous ont encore
conduit à un démarrage vaccinale trop
lent aujourd'hui la problématique est
toute autre et c'est bien bon nombre de
nos concitoyens ne peuvent pas se faire
vacciner en raison d'une trop forte
demande bonne nouvelle et meda stock
limité de vaccins de vaccins et de
centres fermés les rapporteurs ont
également pointé une communication
institutionnelle protéiforme qui n'a pas
su résister aux polémiques il faut
reconnaître que les avis divergent voire
contradictoires du gouvernement certes
mais également du monde scientifique a
créé la confusion exacerbée par les
prises de positions successives des
experts qui ont inondé nos chaînes
d'information en continu
dans un pays caractérisé par une grande
liberté d'expression comment faire mieux
je ne sais pas le discours confus du
démarrage a conduit beaucoup de nos
concitoyens déserté dès la mi mars les
cabinets médicaux j'avais à l'époque
alerté premier ministre et la rs sur les
effets délétères de communiquer inadapté
qui m'était remontées du terrain
d'ailleurs et qui ont mis un certain
temps à se corriger nous nous en
mesurons encore pas aujourd'hui je pense
toutes les conséquences enfin ces
pandémies a mis en évidence une faille
dans un mode d'organisation territoriale
trop centralisée participants
inexorablement à une lenteur dans la
prise de décision c'est ainsi que les
alertes émises dès le mois de février
par la région grand est dont je suis
issue
confronté à une vague épidémique
particulièrement brutales sont restées
sans réponse l'état est intervenu que
plus tard une fois que la région était
dépassé le rapport préconise de définir
les contours d'une nouvelle
ce territoriale et d'une veille
épidémiologique au plus près des
réalités de terrain et c'est absolument
nécessaire faisons davantage confiance
aux îles locaux au personnel soignant
qui ont su faire preuve d'une grande
agilité dès lors qu'ils étaient libérés
de carcans administratifs une
transformation en profondeur est
attendue elle devrait se faire notamment
dans le cadre du projet de loi cadre et
qui prévoit de renforcer la place des
élus dans les futurs conseils
d'administration des ars fin décembre le
président de l'om est déclaré que la
pandémie provoquée par le coronavirus on
ne serez pas la dernière
c'est pourquoi j'espère que nos débats
ouvriront la voie à un nouveau départ
une année zéro de la santé publique les
reporter que les rapporteurs appellent
de leurs voeux et je sauterai
directement à la conclusion pour donner
notre d'espoir j'ai confiance sur la
nature humaine et en sa capacité
d'adaptation
je reste optimiste quant à notre
capacité collective à faire face à ce
satané virus d'ailleurs la france malgré
les difficultés aussi chocolat n'est pas
la plus mauvaise élève de la voix près
merci la parole est maintenant à
laurence cohen pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologistes pour
cinq minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
alors que la campagne de vaccination
contre la coved 19 piétine dans notre
pays
les travaux réalisés par la commission
d' enquête du sénat ont mis en lumière
divers dysfonctionnements et
défaillances sur la gestion de la crise
la pandémie de lakovic 19 et en
filigrane les raisons qui nous ont
conduit à une telle situation
la pandémie pose en réalité une question
essentielle celle du déficit
d'approvisionnement matérielle de
protection en respirateur en médicaments
en test est aujourd'hui en vaccins afin
de répondre aux exigences de réduction
du déficit public
les stocks stratégiques de médicaments
de blues de masse de gand qui était
financier auparavant par la sécurité
sociale ont été laissés à l'abandon avec
le transfert à l'état de la gestion des
stocks de l'établissement de préparation
et de réponse aux urgences sanitaires
eprus lorsqu'il a fallu renouveler les
stocks stratégiques
l'établissement santé publique france a
été dans l'incapacité de réaliser sa
mission
la logique de réduction des dépenses
publiques que nous ne cessons de
dénoncer tout comme les personnels de
santé du médico social a démontré ses
limites et ses contradictions puisque le
coût du renouvellement du stock
stratégique était bien inférieur au coût
des semaines de confinement que nous
avons subi la préparation de votre
gouvernement
les déclarations contradictoires sur
l'utilité des masques la pénurie de lits
de réanimation ne résulte pas d'un
accident de parcours mais bien de choix
stratégiques à l'oeuvre depuis près de
30 ans les conclusions du rapport
sénatorial des montres eux la part de
responsabilité de votre gouvernement par
l'absence d'anticipation de transparence
et de concertation avec les soignants
les élus et les parlementaires le
gouvernement a perdu la confiance de nos
concitoyennes et concitoyens en tentant
de cacher l'insuffisance des stocks de
masques disponibles puis celle des tests
comment ne pas rappeler ici que notre
commission denquête a par ailleurs
montré que le dgs est intervenu pour
faire modifier un rapport d'experts sur
le nombre nécessaire de masques à
commander c'est gravissime
alors que l'état était aux abonnés
absents les villes les départements les
régions ont répondu présent
et se sont mobilisés dès le début pour
commander des masques et assurer leur
cheminement auprès des populations et
ils ont continué avec la mise en place
de centres de test aujourd'hui de
vaccination tout ceci a entraîné des
dépenses considérables pour les
collectivités qui aurait dû être de la
responsabilité de l'état en limitant les
prises de décisions au cercle restreint
du président de la république autour de
certains membres du gouvernement
conseillé par un groupe d'experts et par
des cabinets privés
l' isolement du pouvoir exécutif et la
déconnexion avec la réalité de terrain
n'ont eu de cesse de se renforcer
le parlement est singulièrement le sénat
était réduit à une chambre
d'enregistrement
bafouant ainsi la démocratie des
commissions d'enquêté parlementaires ont
tenté de rétablir la transparence et de
réfléchir à l'avenir en tirant les
enseignements de la première vague de
pandémie et je me réjouis avec
l'ensemble de mon groupe de la création
par le sénat d'une mission d'information
sur l'évaluation des effets des mesures
de confinement qui s'inscrit dans la
continuité des travaux de la commission
denquête je suis convaincu que ces
travaux peuvent être utiles pour toutes
et tous et notamment pour les membres du
gouvernement il ne s'agit pas pour notre
groupe de remettre en cause
l'investissement personnel de vous
monsieur le ministre
oui demande de votre ministère mais de
dénoncer les choix politiques qui ont
conduit à l'affaiblissement des services
publics et à la déstructuration des
outils de l'état la multiplication des
agences a été mise en exergue comme un
frein pour la coordination et
l'efficacité des décisions de nombreuses
auditions dénoncé le nombre insuffisant
de lits de réanimation avec des taux
d'occupation de 90 à 95% empêchant toute
marge de manoeuvre
il est urgent de corriger ce manque de
moyens humains matériels et financiers
dans les hôpitaux publics
et qu'on ne nous répondent pas par le
ségur de la santé qui dans les faits n'a
débouché que sur de timides
revalorisation salariale inégal reid
inégalitaire au demeurant renvoyant à
plus tard l'investissement indispensable
un système de santé devant répondre aux
besoins humains si tel n'est pas la
première leçon à tirer de cette pandémie
alors la dégradation des conditions de
travail va se poursuivre privant
l'hôpital de toute attractivité comme
viennent de me le confirmer les
praticiens hospitaliers
qui sont à bout et sont de plus en plus
nombreux à envisager de partir
gouverner c'est prévoir il est urgent de
répondre à l'exigence d'augmentation
capacitaire dans les hôpitaux à la
reconnaissance des métiers et à une
révision complète de la gouvernance la
démocratie sanitaire est une des clés de
l'attractivité
il faut donner du pouvoir aux personnels
aux usages et aux élus dans les
instances totalement revisité une autre
politique de santé possible en
renforçant les services publics et la
sécurité sociale en dotant les
territoires de structures de proximité
de type centre de santé travaillant en
lien avec les hôpitaux et la médecine de
ville
chaque jour qui passe démontre
l'incapacité de la plupart des grands
labos pharmaceutiques d'organiser une
production et une distribution du vaccin
contre la copie 19
la france doit retrouver sa souveraineté
en ce domaine c'est tout le sens de nos
propositions de création en france et en
europe d'un pôle public du médicament et
de la recherche qui intègre les vaccins
afin d'en faire un bien commun de
l'humanité
je vous remercie merci merci chers
collègues la parole est maintenant à
sylvie vermeillet pour le groupe union
centriste pour sept minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission denquête mes chers collègues
notre commission d' enquête à mener un
travail particulièrement précis et danse
nous avons réalisé 47 auditions et
entendu 133 personnes au rang desquels
d'anciens ou actuels membres du
gouvernement des directeurs généraux de
la santé pas passés et présents des
responsables politiques locaux des
directeurs d'hôpitaux des directeurs
d'aer s des professionnels de santé les
chercheurs 16 ans autorités et bien
d'autres encore le sénat dans la sagesse
qui lui est reconnue a présenté les
conclusions de ses travaux le 8 décembre
dernier et je remercie mon groupe et mes
deux collègues catherine de roche et
bernard jomier de m'avoir fait confiance
pour être co rapporteur de cette
commission denquête les critiques et
recommandations ont été particulièrement
pesé je reviendrai brièvement sur
certaines d'entre elles c'est en étant
lucide sur ce qui a dysfonctionné que
nous pourrons avancer valablement le
retour d'expérience de cette année 2020
doit nous permettre de mettre en oeuvre
les correctifs nécessaires pour que
notre état soit plus réactif dès à
présent sinon travaux ont reçu un écho
médiatique important concernant la
gestion des masques de protection au
printemps 2020 notre rapport ne saurait
être réduit à ce point il est toutefois
symptomatique de ce qui n'a pas
fonctionné
l'absence d'anticipation et de culture
de la gestion de crise au sein du
ministère de la santé
je rappelle un fait le délai d'un mois
entre l' alerte de la ministre agnès
buzyn le 25 décembre 2019 et les
informations qui lui sont communiqués le
24 janvier 2020 sur l'état des stocks de
masques qui a paralysé l'efficience
c'est un retard qui en période de crise
ne se rattrape pas et conditionne la
gestion qui s'ensuit par ailleurs nos
auditions au clairement mis en lumière
les carences dans les premiers temps de
la crise d'une gestion centralisée
l'audition conjointe en juillet dernier
de monsieur jean rottner président de la
région grand test de madame josiane
chevalier préfète de la région grand est
et brigitte klinkert alors présidente du
conseil départemental du haut rhin ainsi
que christophe lannelongue ancien
directeur de la rs grand test fut
particulièrement révélatrice et
émouvante de la situation d'abandon dans
laquelle s'est trouvée le territoire du
grand test face au rouleau compresseur
covit ce sont eux qui ont essuyé les
plâtres essaie de leur expérience
notamment hospitalière que l'échelon
national s'est nourrie pour ensuite
faire face
il serait alors impensable que nous
sachions pas à tirer les conséquences de
cette impréparation pour devenir
meilleur trois de nos réflexions doivent
trouver un écho concret si nous ne
voulons pas répéter nos erreurs
la première vise à renforcer le pilotage
dans la réponse aux urgences sanitaires
avec notamment le rétablissement d'une
fonction de délégué interministériel à
la préparation et à la réponse aux
urgences sanitaires
le dip russe placé auprès du premier
ministre et chargé de coordonner une
vigilance permanente permanente sur
l'état de préparation du pays aux crises
sanitaires ou autres les coûts humains
économiques et financiers actuels
doivent amener chacun d'entre nous à
s'interroger sur les effets d'une
politique de planification de gestion de
crise court termiste de l'état des lieux
des stocks stratégiques de produits de
santé et d'équipements de protection
individuelle à l' actualisation
quotidienne de nos options de plans
d'action il est impératif d'assurer une
veille continue de l'état de préparation
du pays aux catastrophes
en effet la crise du coronavirus aura
montré et montre toujours que la réate
et réactivité des services déconcentrés
de l'état ne peut indéfiniment combler
une mauvaise préparation à la gestion de
crise
le second enseignement sur lequel je
souhaite revenir concerne la gestion
opérationnelle de la crise dans les
établissements médico sociaux et plus
particulièrement la notion de double
tutelle avec la responsabilité distincte
des ars sur le sanitaire et des
départements sur le social dans les
ehpad notamment dans les territoires où
la gestion crise a été une réussite
nous avons constaté que cela tenait
surtout au fait que les délégations
départementales des ars et les conseils
départementaux ont su faire preuve
d'initiative et d'innovation en
travaillant conjointement nos auditions
ont par ailleurs démontré qu'on vient
cette coopération n'était pas naturel
dans d'autres régions où les acteurs
attendait davantage les directives
nationales les difficultés engendrées
par un cloisonnement trop importants
sont apparus insurmontable au démarrage
de la crise et ont fait perdre un temps
précieux pour y faire face les
directeurs d'établissement devait en
permanence changer d'interlocuteur en
fonction de leurs demandes et de leurs
besoins
les difficultés rencontrées dans les
demandes de renforts en personnel ou
l'obtention de masques sont des exemples
notre rapport préconise une unification
de la tutelle le fait de trancher la
question de la gouvernance idéal entre
ars et département n'appartient pas à la
commission d' enquête mais il est
incontournable de rechercher une
alternative à ce double commandement
pour faire face plus efficacement
enfin si la gouvernance nationale doit
être réinventé pour permettre une
réponse efficace au risque pandémique
elle doit parallèlement être accompagnée
d'une refonte de la gouvernance
territoriale de crise nous avons tous
constaté à des degrés divers selon les
territoires que la relation entre
préfets et services des ars a manqué à
minima de fluidité dans mon département
du jura
la délégation ars a fait beaucoup et
bien avec très peu de moyens
cependant j'estime que notre action
gagnerait en efficacité en réaffirmant
un simple fait la gestion de crise
c'est la sphère du ministère de
l'intérieur nous ne ferons pas
l'économie d'une réflexion sur la
clarification du pilotage territorial de
crise sanitaire car ce sont les échelons
déconcentré avec les collectivités
locales qui répondent aujourd'hui encore
à la crise leur préparation les
procédures à appliquer pour travailler
conjointement sont des questions
centrales
la campagne de vaccination est un
exemple des plus actuels de ce besoin
d'anticipation
là encore les préfets les délégués
territoriaux drs les maires les
présidents de collectivités doit
s'adapter et composé du jour au
lendemain pour réparer des erreurs qui
auraient pu être évités depuis plus d'un
an ils sont systématiquement dans
l'urgence monsieur le ministre la
sidération du premier trimestre 2009 1
est loin derrière nous puisque notre
monde a changé puisque nos vies changent
il faut accepter de changer l'état
merci merci chers collègues et pour
clore l'intervention des orateurs et
oratrice la parole à catherine de roche
du groupe l'est républicain pour sept
minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président c'est ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
denquête mes chers collègues dans ce
débat se voudrait concentrer mon propos
sur deux aspects de la gestion de la
crise sanitaire
la gestion territoriale de la crise déjà
évoqué et la recherche la commission
denquête a fait des propositions sur
lesquelles je souhaiterais connaître les
intentions du gouvernement quant à la
suite qui pourra leur être données le
constat a été posée par les intéressés
eux mêmes de la nécessité de renforcer
la fluidité des relations entre les
préfets et les directeurs généraux des
agences régionales de santé
cette question est déterminant pour les
élus locaux plus familier d'une relation
étroite avec le préfet de département
qu'avec directeur général de la rs en
temps de crise l'organisation de cette
relation clairement prévu par le coderst
anti public qui prévoit que le préfet
peut prendre les commandes
ce texte existe et il n'est pas
nécessaire d'en inventer un nouveau
pourtant il n'a pas été utilisé
ce qui nous donne à penser que le défaut
d'organisation était plus générale et
pas seulement liée à l'existence même
des ars c'est pourquoi la commission
denquête à la différence de celle de
l'assemblée nationale n'a pas préconisé
leur suppression
nous avons en revanche souhaité que des
redéploiements interviennent au sein des
ars pour permettre d' armée correctement
les délégations départementales
celles ci sont trop souvent apparu comme
dépourvu d'information de moyens et de
capacité de décision
la réforme des régions en effet percuté
celle des ars dont les sièges sont
souvent trop éloigné du terrain
nous pensons que le délégué
départemental de la rs doit prendre des
responsabilités dans la gestion des
crises en déclinant dans chaque
département un plan pandémie et en
disposant des données épidémiologiques
nécessaire
les cellules d'intervention en région de
santé publique france étant elle même
intégrée au sein des ars
ces données épidémiologiques devrait
également permettre d'apporter des
réponses différenciées à des territoires
placés
dans des situations différentes le cas
emblématique de la première phase a sans
doute été celui de la guyane entrée en
confinement
alors que sa situation ne justifiait pas
forcément est privé de cette mesure en
pleine flambée de l'épidémie
le pilotage à crise alors clairement
apparu comme trop centralisée il ne
semble pas que ce point est
significativement évolué dans la durée
en matière de recherche l'effort a été
tout à fait exceptionnelle et les
résultats au delà des attentes que nous
pouvions avoir le développement des
vaccins en est un exemple
en france pourtant il est apparu que cet
effort de resserre c'était trop
dispersible et qu'il a de fait conduit à
des résultats limités
nous sommes bien sûr favorable à liberté
la recherche et à la diversité des
initiatives seul à même de produire des
résultats dans un contexte de crise et
d'urgence et nous sommes cependant que
la multiplication des essais cliniques
consacré aux mêmes molécules en
dispersant des financements et en
réduisant mécaniquement le nombre de
patients inséré dans les différents bras
a clairement nui à l'efficacité de la
recherche
confrontés aux mêmes enjeux les
britanniques ont déployé à l'exemple de
l'essai recovery promu par l'université
d'oxford un effort de recherche beaucoup
mieux coordonnée
c'était ça a été défini comme un essai
de haute priorité nationale dont tous
les médecins ont été informés il nous
sommes qu'une démarche similaire aurait
pu être conduites en france
il nous semble nécessaire que les
ministères chargés de la santé de la
recherche puisse assurer la définition
de travaux prioritaires qui pourraient
concentrer les financements
exceptionnels mobilisés pendant la crise
la chance nationale de sécurité du
médicament n'a pas la capacité juridique
de remplir cette mission
pas plus qu'elle n'a été en mesure dans
la cacophonie ambiante de faire entendre
une voix autorisée sur la méthodologie
en matière de recherche clinique
laissant se dérouler sur la place
publique des controverses qui n'ont fait
qu'alimenter le désarroi et la défiance
de nos concitoyens il nous est également
apparu que la recherche sur les maladies
émergentes infectieuses
gagnerait à mieux se structurer c'était
l'objet du consortium reacting qui n'a
pu assurer que partiellement cette
mission et vous pourrez précisé monsieur
le ministre les missions et les moyens
de la nouvelle agence dont vous avez
annoncé la création à partir de
réactiver la commission denquête avait
pour sa part recommandé la création
d'une structure dédiée à la recherche en
maladies infectieuses en rapprochant le
consortium writing de l' agence
nationale de la recherche sur le sida et
les maladies infectieuses dont la
mission est de fédérer coordonner animer
et financer toute la recherche publique
sur le sida et les hépatites virales
cette capacité à fédérer nous à clermont
fait défaut dans la recherche contre la
cage vide
d'une façon plus générale quels sont les
enseignements que le gouvernement tire
de cette crise en matière de recherche
tout comme à l'hôpital le secteur de la
recherche tout comme l'hôpital c'est
dans la recherche était en crise et en
proie au doute
bien avant le déclenchement de
l'épidémie covin qu'elle celui-ci
envisagez-vous pour la promo réalisation
de la recherche alors que les résultats
ont pour le moment plutôt été dégagés à
l'étranger
je vous remercie bien merci chers
collègues la parole est maintenant à
monsieur le ministre
olivier verront ministre des solidarités
et de la santé
merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs l'épidémie est
encore là elle nous oblige à la plus
grande vigilance dans notre vie
quotidienne comme dans les analyses et
les jugements qui ne saurait être
définitif l'heure n'est donc pas encore
au bilan même s'il n'est jamais trop tôt
ou trop tard pour un débat démocratique
il ya un an virus était encore très
largement un mystère a percé une menace
abstraite un risque mal définie
aujourd'hui c'est un ennemi mieux
identifier qui a sévi partout dans le
monde
partout dans le monde provoquant plus de
80 mille morts dans notre pays
nous faisons donc face à une épidémie
qui est évolutive que nous suivons
chaque jour heure par heure avec des
connaissances qui elle aussi évoluent
sans cesse
tout comme évoluent les outils qui nous
permettent de lutter avec toujours plus
d'efficacité contre ce virus
je salue une nouvelle fois toutes celles
et tous ceux qui se mobilisent depuis
des mois de longs mois sans compter leur
temps ni leur énergie
c'est tout notre système de santé qui a
été mis en tension comme jamais ce sont
toutes les structures économiques et
sociales de notre pays qui ont été
bouleversés ce sont tous les français
qui ont dû apprendre à vivre autrement
pour éviter le pire il a été question de
première ligne de deuxième ligne le
troisième ligne
ce qui est sûr c'est que nous vivons une
épreuve collective majeur une épreuve
inconnu de notre génération de la mienne
de la vôtre une épreuve qui n'épargne
personne et qui demande à chacun des
efforts et même des sacrifices une crise
c'est une perte de contrôle
c'est un événement qui surgit qui prend
de court qui nous dépasse d'abord et
auquel nous nous adaptons ensuite
aujourd'hui nous avons davantage
solutions pour combattre l'épidémie et
nous avons repris sur elle une forme de
contrôle relatif
la vaccination est un espoir formidable
un outil aussi puissant qu'il espérait
il ya encore quelques semaines mais
regardez mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs des variants apparaissent déjà
qui se développe aux quatre coins du
monde qui posent de nouvelles questions
de nouvelles difficultés de nouveaux
défis qui peuvent mettre à mal notre
stratégie
bien malin qui ici est capable de dire
avec certitude ce que
le virus nous posera encore comme défi
dans les semaines les mois à venir non
c'est churchill qui avait pour coutume
de dire qu'un bon palier un bon
politicien est celui qui est capable de
prédire l'avenir et qui par la suite est
également capable d'expliquer pourquoi
les choses ne se sont pas passées comme
il l'avait prédit
je pense qu'en la matière les
prédictions n'ont jamais été d'une
grande aide dans la conduite des
politiques publiques et nous devons
rester à la fois modeste et à la fois
considérer qu'il ya des choses qui
aujourd'hui nous échappent et pour
lesquels nous aurons des réponses demain
et heureusement nous les aurons à ce
jour à l'heure où nous parlons nous
disposons de temps intermédiaire mais la
ligne d'arrivée n'a pas été franchie le
travail d'analysé doit impérativement
tenir compte de cette donnée pour autant
ce travail est indispensable et nous
devons préparer ensemble notre système
de santé pour demain on appelle cela
tirer les enseignements c'est notre
responsabilité désengage fort des
engagements forts ont déjà été pris par
exemple avec les figures de la santé qui
répondait à des revendications anciennes
et légitime porté par les soignants nous
avons revalorisé dans des proportions
inédites les métiers du soin nous avons
investi comme jamais pour donner à
l'hôpital public les moyens d'affronter
autant le quotidien que les épreuves de
grande ampleur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je suis engagé dans la gestion
de cette crise sanitaire depuis la
première minute de ma prise de fonction
dans quelques jours cela fera un an que
j'aurais été nommé ministre en charge
des solidarités de la santé par temps
calme ce ministère n'est pas un
ministère comme les autres puisqu'il
touche à ce que chacun de plus précieux
sa santé et celle de ses proches
dans la tempête ce ministère cristallise
les attentes
les espoirs les angoisses de tout un
pays en franchissant les portes du
ministère je savais que ma
responsabilité serait immense et j'ai
chaque jour mesurer ses attentes ses
espoirs et ses angoisses
je n'ai pas à commenter en différé
j'agis en temps réel et l'intérêt
général a été ma seule boussole
je vous remercie
bien dans la suite du débat merci
monsieur le ministre dans la suite du
débat chaque orateur dispose de deux
minutes maximum pour présenter sa
question avec une réponse du
gouvernement pour une durée équivalente
dans le cas où l'auteur de la question
souhaite répliquer il dispose de 30
secondes supplémentaires à la condition
que le temps initial de deux minutes
n'est pas été dépassé je donne la parole
pour commencer à madame angèle préville
du groupe socialiste pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
si la réponse à l'urgence peut être par
essence imparfaite des leçons durables
auraient dû être tirée de la crise les
choix politiques les égarements
stratégiques n'ont pas été assumée nous
le regrettons
l'ampleur du choc ressenti par notre
pays depuis bientôt un an et inédite
nous faisons face à un bilan humain sans
précédent à une urgence sanitaire et
social le début de crise a été marqué
par un manque d'anticipation une absence
de prise de décision et une accumulation
des dénis la première défiance est la
vôtre à l'égard des français pointé du
doigt comme aux élèves peu respectueux
des consignes accusé d'emblée d'être de
potentiels vecteurs de la maladie aux
comportements insouciants ce qui en
résulte en principe de réaction c'est
une défiance en retour accentuée par
l'incompréhension de vos mesures
nous nous inquiétons sur les leçons qui
peine à émerger car la vulnérabilité de
notre société a été mise à nu or la
gestion de la crise a été concentrée
dans une certaine forme d'opacité par le
truchement du conseil de défense entre
les mains de l'exécutif
elle accuse aujourd'hui le coût de sa
verticalité notre démocratie a été mise
à mal la stratégie des masques des tests
et des vaccins n'a clairement pas été à
la hauteur avec l'impression persistante
d'être toujours en retard ma question
porte sur l' expertise sur le rôle du
conseil scientifique mise en place à la
hâte
n'aurait-on pas dû avoir d'entrée de jeu
une instance autonome pérenne
multidisciplinaire indépendante dotée de
moyens conséquents est capable de faire
face aux crises à venir
dépassant le strict champ des pandémies
comme des événements climatiques ou des
accidents industriels par exemple ce qui
est une proposition de notre rapport
jour merci
il ya un merci pour la question monsieur
le ministre madame la sénatrice
on pourrait disserter longtemps sur le
fait de savoir si une crise sont ici
puisque par définition c'est une crise
et anticiper il ya moins de risque
qu'elle survienne
elle a éclaté en france elle a éclaté
dans toute l'europe elle a éclaté dans
le monde entier on peut considérer qu'il
ya peut-être un facteur qui échappe aux
politiques publiques et aux particuliers
particularité inhérentes un pays
et quand une crise éclate puisque par
définition n'était pas anticipable
surtout quand elle est mondiale les
réactions que vous devez avoir les
décisions vous devez prendre
elle ne se prennent pas part
l'anticipation de ce que vous pourrez
décider dans un mois vous êtes d'accord
avec moi
donc quand j'ai souhaité avoir un comité
scientifique ad-hoc pour pouvoir
éclairer les décisions de politiques
publiques répondre à des questions qui
se pose est qui était découverte au jour
le jour j'allais dire
heure après heure oui ce conseil
scientifique été mis en place à la hâte
mais les décisions prises à la hâte
madame la sénatrice si on ne le fait pas
quand on gérer une crise alors on ne
gère pas une crise quant à la question
démocratique c'est et je ne dis ça sans
aucune sans aucune forme de critique et
je suis profondément respectueux
j'allais dire presque amoureux du
parlement j'ai été parlementaire et
j'aime le parlement lorsqu'il est
capable d'apporter et j'aime
profondément la démocratie et je suis
très attaché à ce que la démocratie
puisse survivre même dans des périodes
de crise c'est ainsi que c'est ma 24e la
24e convocation par une chambre
parlementaire assemblée nationale ou
sénat depuis onze mois que je suis
ministre à laquelle je réponds bien
volontiers je vous en remercie
d'ailleurs pour cette convocation qui
s'ajoute aux nombreux séance et textes
de lois qui ont traité de la crise
sanitaire je ne vous pas l'impression
que la démocratie et été confisqués je
pense avoir presque passer plus de temps
au parlement communiste j'en avais passé
comme étant député mais cela étant je
comprends parfaitement les remarques qui
peuvent être formulées sur l'enjeu
démocratique en période de crise à
nouveau on pourrait disserter longtemps
sur ce sujet merci monsieur le ministre
madame préville vous avez droit à une
réplique oui merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre
je pense que vous n'avez pas bien
compris ce que je vous ai demandé je
vous ai demandé s'il n'aurait pas été
intéressant d'avoir d'emblée déjà une
instance prête à répondre à toutes les
crises auxquelles nous allons peut-être
être confronté à l'avenir c'était là ma
question est ce que est évidemment que
le conseil scientifique et j'ai dit à la
hâte parce qu'il n'y avait rien c'était
pour cela et parce que je pense que
comme cela existe dans d'autres pays
notamment les pays anglo saxons nous
aurons à l'avenir on va espérer que non
mais à faire face à d'autres crises
importantes également qu'ils sont comme
je les dis des événements climatiques ou
des accidents industriels et que d'avoir
d'emblée une instance multidisciplinaire
avec des scientifiques qui sont très
quasiment à la seconde à répondre et à
venir qu'il faut oui pardon peut-être
que ça aurait été une chose intéressante
voilà c'était ma question d'un parole à
guillaume gontard pour le groupe
écologiste pour deux minutes
oui merci merci monsieur le président
messieurs le monsieur le ministre je
voulais d'abord m'excuser de sortir un
petit peu du cadre du présent rapport
pour évoquer davantage la question de la
gouvernance qui me semble essentiel en
prenant quelques instants pour regarder
comment nos voisins gère la pandémie
depuis un an on constate rapidement
qu'aucune démocratie ne fonctionne avec
une telle verticalité ce qui était
acceptable il ya un nom est devenu
insupportable aujourd'hui j'en rappelle
brièvement qui après avoir été au
théâtre pour rassurer les français début
mars le président de la république a
décidé huit jours plus tard sans aucun
cadre légal de confiner le pays nous
nous y tenons pas rigueur une décision
qui s'impose est que nous avons
d'ailleurs valider a posteriori mais je
mobilise cet exemple pour préciser que
notre politique de gestion de crise ne
peut plus relevé du seul président
l'exemple du confinement avortée il ya
quinze jours qui a pris par surprise
jusqu'au premier ministre on est une
nouvelle illustration délétère ce manque
de visibilité est aussi pesant et zain
pour nos concitoyens que les mesures de
restriction et et de liberté alors que
faire que faire face à cette crise
qui est quand même parti pour pour durer
hélas il me semble que l'afrique du sud
pays pourtant très durement touchée par
le virus a pris le temps d'élaborer un
mode de gouvernance intéressant en lien
avec le parlement le gouvernement a mis
en place à bahreïn avec 5 niveaux d'
alerte à la manière de notre barème
vigipirate
chaque niveau correspond progressivement
un certain nombre de mesures de
distanciation et de restriction de la
liberté de mouvement et d'activités le
changement de niveau est activé par le
gouvernement sur la base de critères
objectifs circulation du virus donc de
décès niveau d'occupation des hôpitaux
avec dation possibilité de
territorialisation monsieur le ministre
qu'est ce qui empêche le gouvernement de
travailler sur un tel dispositif où un
dispositif semblable est en tout cas de
travailler sur le temps long sur
l'adaptation comme vous en avez parlé
qui permettrait donner de la visibilité
aux français et aux françaises et aux
élus locaux aux entreprises et surtout
de rang faire renforcer l'acceptabilité
des mesures et soulager notre démocratie
monsieur le ministre mais monsieur le
sénateur guy augmenté remercie pour
votre question d'abord en gestion de
crise faut je pense distinguer la
préparation la décision et la
formalisation la décision en pratique la
préparation et des décisions allaient
collégiale des scientifiques les élus
vous avez participé à plusieurs reprises
au comité d'élus avec le premier
ministre et j étais également il ya de
l'expertisé sanitaire
ensuite y'a une des discussions
interministérielles et à la fin il faut
bien qu'ils aient une décision qui soit
prise dans une mission régalienne le
chef de l'état engage sa responsabilité
et prend les décisions mais ça veut pas
dire qu'il décide ça la formalisation la
décision est seul mais elle fait suite à
des concertations je peux vous dire je
passe beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
temps dans ces concertations et
heureusement et c'est très important
enfin il faut je comprends la volonté du
procès politique parce que je le vois
émerger une partie de la gauche depuis
quelques semaines sur un homme qui
décideraient tout seul et ça ne je peux
vous dire que ça ne traduit absolument
pas la réalité des choses ce qu'elles
sont conduites et l'effort de
transparence qui est fait tous les
jeudis
avec des ministres le dgs pour expliquer
des choses montre un transparence les
graphes les données les chiffres
vraiment non seulement communiquer les
choses mais s'attacher à ce que les gens
comprennent et saisissent les enjeux et
je crois que les français d'ailleurs ont
saisi les enjeux et les comprennent ont
permis d'indicateurs de ça et on en a
fait à plusieurs reprises des zonages
avec des zones rouges on nous a reproché
qui avait trop de zones après canal pas
assez après qu'elle était trop uniforme
après qu'elle était trop
territorialisées ce n'est pas grave la
critique peut faire aussi progressé ce
que je veux dire c'est quelque chose qui
nous ne nous permettent pas aujourd'hui
encore de vous dire voilà dans un mois
quelle sera la situation
c'est le sénateur pendant juste avant
vous posez votre question j'ai regardé
comme je le fais tous les jours à la
même heure les publications de chiffres
d'épidémie du jour par santé publique
france quand je sortirai ce débat je
pourrai enfin prendre connaissance du
taux de saturation des reals par région
pour voir si un département dans lequel
sa montée si ça montre regarder si c'est
pas ce qui est du carillon et s'il ya du
variant appelée localement pour voir si
c'est un cluster et c'est un cluster ça
va mais si c'est une diffusion
départementale ont dit oui à la haye ce
que ça peut apporter des conséquences en
terme de décisions petit public
c'est notre quotidien depuis un an
monsieur le sénateur la réactivité est
absolument indispensable donc
transparence règles claires vous avez
raison assumer les décisions ça c'est la
constitution qui le veut et par contre
réactivité et il faut nous laisser cette
réactivité la parole à madame cathy
apourceau poly du groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologistes pour
deux minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre le rapport de la commission d'
enquête du sénat a démontré que le
gouvernement aurait pu anticiper la
deuxième vague de covile 19 bien plus
tôt malheureusement vous n'avez pas
écouté les mises en garde et surtout
tirer les leçons des échecs de la
gestion de la pandémie au premier
trimestre 2009 1 face à la crise des
solutions alternatives ont émergé d'été
des territoires les maires les élus se
sont mobilisés pour la fabrication de
masques je pense également aux
initiatives de fabrication de masques
lavables au sein de la filière textile
la commission d'enquêté sénatoriale
préconise d'ailleurs de promouvoir ces
masques produits en france est de
pérenniser la filière la mise à
disposition d'une production nationale
de masques grand public mobilisable
rapidement au cas de crise sanitaire est
aujourd'hui nécessaire
monsieur le ministre depuis lundi l'
usage des masques artisanes artisanaux
sont interdits à l'école et les masques
de catégorie 1 sont obligatoires
actuellement aucune homologation est
prévue pour la commercialisation des
masques que prévoit le gouvernement pour
aider les initiatives locales de
production de masques de la filière
textile pour obtenir la certification de
catégorie 1
afin de maintenir cette activité sur
notre territoire et enfin nous vous
proposons envoyé à chaque enfant
scolarisé des masques de catégorie 1 en
passant par les communes ou par les
communautés d'agglomération qu'en pensez
vous je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre
la sénatrice
la france a été le premier pays européen
à mettre en place des normes afnor avec
deux catégories de filtration pour des
masques dits grand public c'était un
gros travail qui a été qu'ils étaient
fournis les industriels ont été très
rapidement mobilisés pour produire et
dans toutes les entreprises dont
beaucoup d'entreprises françaises
notamment ce qui nous a permis
d'améliorer considérablement la capacité
à protéger des français avec des avec
des masques vous le savez les
collectivités ont joué tous leurs rôles
qui ont acquis des masses qui ont 15 ans
distribuer l'état également puisque nous
avons réalisé le troisième envoi de 45
millions de masques gratuits à 7
millions de français précaire chez eux
et le troisième des stockages de
plusieurs dizaines de millions de
masques à usage unique destiné aux
personnes qui sont qui sont qui vivent à
la rue et qui ne peuvent pas laver laver
leur masque vous posez la question de
l'accessibilité de ces masques et bien
écoutez je vous en ai parlé pour tout ce
qui est du réseau associatif des élus
locaux des collectivités aussi et de
l'état pour les enfants il y à des
distributions de masquer textile qui
sont organisés via les préfectures à
destination des structures associatives
dans les territoires pour évidemment
permettre aux enfants et l'issue de
familles modestes de pouvoir se protéger
en ayant ces masques grand public deux
catégories une main pour sue police oui
monsieur le ministre j'entends votre
réponse sur les familles modestes mais
comment vont faire les familles qui sont
aujourd'hui plongés dans la précarité
les familles y compris on n'en parle pas
souvent mais qui gagne le smic
vous savez qu'un axe un masque pour un
enfant c'est 3 euros en moyenne
ça fait 150 euros
l'année pour un enfant donc voilà ça
représente quand même un sacré un sacré
souci est donc j'aimerais savoir est ce
que vous êtes d'accord pas avec cette
proposition de fournir à tous les
enfants scolarisés un masque qu'il soit
dans une famille où on gagne le smic ou
dans une famille où évidemment on vit la
précarité parce que quand même juste
pour dire un monsieur le ministre que
les familles ont connu le chômage
partiel et qu'elles ont eu de grosses
pertes de pouvoir d'achat
la parole est à jean françois busson des
républicains oui messieurs c'est le
président de ses ministres comme un
certain nombre de nos collègues je vais
revenir sur un ensemble des conclusions
de cette commission denquête notamment
touchant à la gestion de la crise dont
je rappelle que le présent la république
l'a qualifié de temps de guerre et qui
n'a manifestement pas permis d'assurer à
la fois une territorialisation dynamique
des décisions qui auraient permis nous
semble-t-il de mieux gérer la crise dans
les territoires et notamment dans le
premier acte les territoires les plus
touchés je pense à notre région la
région grand est mais également de
ralentir dans un second temps la
propagation du virus
par ailleurs vous n'avez pas permis de
doter les acteurs locaux dans cette de
ce premier temps d'un soutien suffisant
lors donnant les moyens d'action alors à
cette époque loi d'être linéaire la mise
en oeuvre de la stratégie de lutte
contre le coc u19 c'est plutôt apparenté
à une course d'obstacles
il a fallu aux ars trouvé le moyen de
d'avoir la bonne trajectoire pour gérer
la crise sanitaire il y a eu besoin de
l'aide
évidemment des départements et des
communes
et puis finalement une stratégie
nationale hésitante par les services de
l'état
autant de disques décisionnaire qui ont
ralenti la chaîne de commandement lourde
à ce moment-là inadaptation de la crise
est la fluidité gage de confiance
monsieur le ministre comment aujourd'hui
pensez-vous remédier à cette gestion
lente et désordonnée de la crise
sanitaire qui participe je dois le dire
d'une certaine manière au climat
anxiogène ressentie par les français
le monsieur le ministre
bref dans les débats tout à leur pupitre
il beaucoup de choses qui ont été dites
sur le grand test et ça me gêne un peu
donc je vais profiter de votre question
sur le sénateur pour répondre le grand
est c'est une région qui a pris la crise
de plein fouet
oui une région dans laquelle nous avons
été bons en particulier en contact avec
la quasi totalité des grands élus du
territoire qu'ils soient maires
présidents de départements de région
quasiment au quotidien c'est le
territoire dans laquelle nous avons
réalisé le plus d'évacuation sanitaire
en urgence
c'est le territoire de france dans
lequel vous avez eu le plus de soignants
compris un jour le train ou la voiture
pour venir prêter main forte pour éviter
que l'on soit obligé de faire du tri de
malades à l'hôpital
c'est ça la région grand est ce monsieur
le sénateur c'est une région qui nous a
occupée jour et nuit pendant des
semaines pendant des semaines
j'ai donc du mal à laisser dire que la
région aurait été laissée seule
abandonnée livrée à elle même ce n'est
menacée parce que vous avez dit c'est ce
qui était dit tout à l'heure par
quelqu'un de la région qui en est qui
qui parlait de cela et la région grand
est ce monsieur sénateurs c'est la
région où j'ai dû limoger un directeur
général derrière est-ce que vous avez
auditionné dans votre commission
denquête g non pas que pour d'autres
raisons monsieur le sénateur il n'a pas
que pour d'autres raisons
et on attend monsieur le sénateur jeu
est légale en lien étroit avec les élus
locaux je note que quand les élus locaux
étaient quasi unanime pour demander est
ce qu'on remplace le dg de la rs je me
suis exécuté ce qui n'a pas empêché
qu'il soit auditionné pour comprendre si
les raisons pour lesquelles nous
l'avions limogés et est bonne ou non
voilà monsieur le sénateur
suzon pardon monsieur le ministre vous
finalement vous dans votre réponse vous
êtes un peu fourvoyé sur le limogeage du
directeur de la rs moi je vais vous dire
la raison la raison c'est pas celle ci
c'est des choix que vous pourriez vous
qualifier d'inacceptables houde
hasardeuse ce que ce qu'on dit un
certain nombre d'élus sur l'organisation
du chr chu de nancy et enfin je voulais
vous faire non mais si la réalité c'est
celle ci monsieur ministre
la réalité c'est celle ci la deuxième
chose je vais vous faire une petite
proposition parce qu'elle relève
finalement du travail d' influence que
pourrait avoir le gouvernement à
l'endroit des organismes d'assurance des
complémentaires santé plutôt que de
négocier ou de demander à ce qu'il paye
pour participer à des contributions il
eût été préférable
et il est encore temps par exemple qu'au
titre des dépenses de prévention prévus
par les contrats couvrant l'ensemble des
français viennent complémentaire santé
la prise en compte d'une partie des
frais pour les masques soit finalement
une solution qui soit apportée ce qui
permettrait de montrer que le public et
privé peuvent travailler intelligemment
au service des français
bien merci chers collègues la parole à
vincent delahaye pour le groupe union
centriste pour deux minutes
mes chers collègues pendant deux mois la
direction générale de la santé
enjoignait chaque soir les français à
faire preuve de responsabilité face au
co vide
aujourd'hui les français sont en droit
de demander à l'administration de faire
preuve de la même responsabilité
or qu'est-ce que la responsabilité c'est
l'obligation de répondre de ses actes et
le cas échéant de ses fautes
je me concentrerai ici sur quelques unes
de celles commises par la direction
générale de la santé la lecture de notre
rapport permet d'identifier trois fautes
majeures la dissimulation d'abord mis au
courant dès 2018 de la non-conformité
delà du caractère périssable de
centaines de millions de masques
la direction générale de la santé n'en a
fermé sciemment pas la ministre de la
santé
l'impréparation ensuite la direction
générale de la santé décidé de ne pas
reconstituer ce stock
toujours sans en informer le
gouvernement et par là même les français
la manipulation enfin
la pénurie arriver la direction générale
de la santé faisait pression pour
modifier un avis scientifique sur la
nécessité de disposer d'un stock élevé
de masques dissimulation impréparation
manipulation trois fautes majeures
aucune responsabilité
malgré cela le gouvernement n'a eu de
cesse de renouveler sa confiance à la
direction générale de la santé pourquoi
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre cette position est intenable
maintenant que la lumière est faite sur
les erreurs commises quelles
conséquences comptez vous en tirer
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
sénateur je crois pas être devant une
cour de justice à répondre d'accusations
au nom de mon directeur général de la
santé donc j'ai déjà eu à m'exprimer sur
cette question là j'ai lu le rapport de
commission denquête les éléments qui
sont qui figure dans que dans le rapport
ont été envoyés par le directeur général
de la santé lui-même j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion d'expliquer à plusieurs fois
qu'il avait toute ma confiance et que je
remercie pour l'action qu'il mène au
service de l'intérêt général je vous
remercie monsieur dollars
j'avoue que beaucoup de français sont
surpris que de ce genre de réponse
moi même je suis surpris il ya une
gestion quand même catastrophique des
masques c'est reconnu il ya une gestion
chaotique des tests aujourd'hui on a une
préparation flagrante de la campagne de
vaccination
on se demande ce qui s'est passé depuis
le mois de septembre pour préparer cette
campagne de vaccination alors qu'on
savait qu'on allait avoir des vaccins
on se demande ce que la direction
générale de la santé a fait pendant ce
temps là et moi je considère que quand
on est aux responsabilités
on doit rendre des comptes et
aujourd'hui on a l'impression que la
haute fonction publique ne rend pas de
compte
donc on a on a besoin quand même d'avoir
des explications un peu plus clair et un
peu plus large que ce qui a été dit par
monsieur me dise moi je suis désolé de
cette réponse parce qu'elle ne
correspond pas du tout à ce qu'on peut
attendre d'une responsable d'une
administration responsable dans notre
pays pour conclure le débat la parole et
comme monsieur alain milon au nom de la
commission donc elle oui merci monsieur
le président monsieur me disent mes
chers collègues
l'heure n'est pas encore au bilan
nous a indiqué le miz la santé en
réponse discussion générale
c'est sans doute pourquoi sa réponse a
été si brève témoignant à l'évidence
d'une certaine lassitude à rendre compte
devant le parlement malgré l'amour
programme est proclamée à son égard vous
avez monsieur le ministre cité churchill
permettez moi de vous citer shakespeare
qui disait il n'ya pas d'amour il n'ya
que des preuves d'amour répondre aux
parlementaires peut en être une
je 24 convocation devant le parlement en
un an
cela fait deux par mois une fois par
mois dans chaque chambre
cela ne me semble pas nécessaire pour
nous lasser ou pour vous là c'est
surtout quand on aime
je regrette notamment que vous n'ayez
pas répondu sur la question de l'
isolement question qui me semble encore
ouverte et plus généralement sur la
stratégie tester tracé isolés et les
raisons pour lesquelles elle est devenue
tester alerté protégés sur la recherche
qu'elle soit financée par le public ou
le privé
la question du financement est posée
elle a été posée les sociétés france de
la société française valdi va à trouver
des financements britanniques les
allemands ont su financer des biotech la
france ne parvient pas à financer ces
bio tech et surtout à fidéliser ces
chercheurs
la temporalité a été évoquée monsieur
ministre ainsi que le temps long
j'entends ces arguments mais empruntant
les français n'ont pas compris pourquoi
en dépit des déclarations du
gouvernement ils n'avaient pas de masque
il était de notre devoir je dis pas de
votre mais de notre devoir de chercher à
comprendre d'autant que dans ce domaine
la stratégie et le discours a clairement
été dicté par les capacités sur ce
dossier le timing de la commission
denquête à l'issue de la première vague
était le bon nous ne parlons plus de
masques
sur les masques non monsieur le ministre
un commission denquête ne s'est pas
focalisé sur un nombre
elle a proposé une méthode et un schéma
d'organisation
c'est très différent je récuse
l'accusation de politique politicienne
vous n'en trouverez pas trace dans le
rapport j'entends bien que les tests
gratuits ce que les tests sont gratuits
mais cela ne rend pas pour autant leur
usage efficace pour casser les chaînes
de contamination nous ne tirerons les
leçons de la crise la condition
d'accepter d'entrer dans cette logique
et d'accepter le débat
à l'évidence ce travail reste à faire
fort heureusement et je répondre sur une
réponse que vous avez donné un peu
énervé fort heureusement monsieur le
ministre le contrôle de l'action du
gouvernement et de l'administration ne
se fait pas uniquement devant les
tribunaux la commission d'enquêté n'a
jamais jamais appelé à traduire
quiconque devant la cour de justice
elle a appelé à changer le mode de
fonctionnement une véritable agence
sanitaire ne voit pas ses conclusions
modifié par le directeur
d'administration centrale
c'est ça le sens de nos recommandations
et jeunes actifs ne s'être pas sur ce
sujet en particulier de caricatures
merci et bonne soirée
[Musique]